Welcome to the lecture on database implementation.
So in the last lecture, we started looking at set-oriented query processing.
And we said that for efficiency reasons, we prefer processing schemes where we don't look at individual data items, but instead look at large sets of items.
Because we can process much more efficiently than if we just look at one item after the other.
For example, we can use techniques like sorging, hashing, indexing, etc.
So that pay off if you have large sets, but for a single table, of course, an index doesn't
make sense.
So therefore, we prefer to process large sets of data values.
And we said, usually we do this by expressing our query processing plan or strategy as relational
algebra.
So here we see a typical example, if you would run a SQL query that says, find me all students
that attend lectures and databases, this is what we get.
So we would look at one set here, this set or this relation more precisely, this relation
we join together, this gives us, at least conceptually, gives us a new relation.
We might not store it like this, but conceptually this gives me a new relation.
Then I have the lectures relation again, I construct a new relation by filtering on database
title and then we join them together and then we get the answer.
So our model here is that the operators that we have and operators are join, select, this
is select, join, select, and this here you don't see it because we usually write the
name of the relation, but this is called a table scan.
So an operator that reads a table from disk or from memory.
And so in each operator consumes zero or more relations and produces one output relation.
So this is our model here.
And this processing model is inherently set oriented because it operates on set of data.
Now when I say set of data, this is strictly speaking not true because SQL allows us to
have duplicates in our input.
If we don't have a primary key, then we can have duplicates.
Therefore, the algebra here is back-oriented.
So we are multi-set oriented.
So we can have multiple copies of the same data value,
which actually sometimes is a pain.
Some of the problems become more difficult,
because we can have duplicates.
If everything would be duplicate-free,
this would usually be easier.
But SQL is not like this.
So we must cope with the fact that we might have duplicates.
Now what interests us in this lecture, of course, is how do we implement this?
So how do we implement such algebraic operators?
And later we look at how really we implement them.
So before we look at individual operators, you must understand what are the general strategies
for doing so.
And now one thing you must keep in mind is that there are actually multiple points in
time, if you wish.
And so this here at time point T1, we compile our database system.
Of course this is usually a long time ago, so this has been very, like weeks, months,
years ago, that's a long time ago.
So then sometime later, at T2, we compile the query,
and so some SQL query, for example SQL.
And then of course, again at some point later,
now this is probably closer to T2,
but can at least conceptually also be quite late,
we execute the query.
In particular, this separation causes quite a few challenges, but first let's look at
the one between T1 and T2.
One problem of course is that when we build our database systems, when we implement it,
when we test this, we have no idea which queries will be executed later in our system.
Because we built a database system, we often ship it to a customer, so we might run it
on a cloud server instead, but nevertheless, we installed it somewhere.
And then it is more or less out of our control.
And at some later point in time, a user types in some SQL,
and of course, then expects this works.
So, this means that you must implement your operators in a way
that they can cope with arbitrary queries.
And because we don't know the queries,
so when we implement operators, we don't know which queries will be executed.
Therefore, we must implement them in a way,
so that they can land everything.
And to illustrate this, of course, we will see more examples later, but just to illustrate
this, think about, let's say we want to implement something like set intersection.
So we want to take two sets or two relations and now we want to find all values that occur
in both sides, both sets.
So regular set intersection.
And now what we want, and of course we have no idea what this set will be like.
Is it an integer column, is it a string column, is it two columns, we have no idea.
Nevertheless we must implement our intersection in a way that always works.
And one way to do this is to assume that we have a kind of abstract helper logic, we will
usually call them subscripts.
So we call subscripts because we attach them to the operator
when we write it down.
So we have a subscript and this contains
a query specific part.
Like so we have might have here our intersect operator
here on top.
So this here might be our intersect.
I then say, okay, to an input intersect
I need three operations.
First, it must be possible to read my left input.
So I need a function that gives me my left input.
I need a function that gives me my right input.
and I need a function that compares two elements from both inputs.
And now in reality we might need more than this, but this is indeed about the smallest
way we can interplay into intersection because if you think about this, what we can do is,
at least one way to implement this is to say, I read my left input and then I sort my left
input and I can do this because I have a comparison function. So I sort my left input,
then I read my right input and again I sort my right input and I can do this with the comparison
function. And then I scan both lists which are sorted and find all elements that occur on both
sides. And again I can do this because of my comparison function. Now often you will not
want to implement it like this. For example you might prefer hash tables instead of sorting,
but then we need more subscripts. For example we might have what's written down here,
We might need a function,
need a way to hash a value from left or right.
And so we need hash functions or some other stuff.
But this is of course depends on our implementation,
but this is about the minimum set.
So with these three operators,
these three subscripts, you can implement this.
And note that this,
how this implementation actually makes no assumption
about the tuples at all.
Now, if I say at all, it's not a hundred percent true.
a large value is because if I change the sort order,
I might, but perhaps if not,
because I can do everything with indirection.
And so it might be okay to not even know
how large the data items is,
because what I can always do is I have here,
these are my data items.
So just written, oh, sorry, this is here,
A, B, C or something.
And so we can just maintain a pointer array to all this,
points to the first value, points to the second value,
points to the third value.
and then I can just sort the pointers using the comparison function.
So because I look at the content and then I call the comparison function.
So I might call this pointer values instead,
and then I don't even have to know how large the values themselves are.
So I can implement an intersection knowing very, very little about the input.
Data types, doesn't matter.
Well, size of the tuple depends on how we implement it, but might not matter either.
We just have to know, okay, how can I get my pointers to my left side?
How can I get my pointers to my right side?
And how can I compare two elements?
So this is everything that I really need to know.
This is an interesting way to implement operators.
Of course, of course, it's not only interesting because for database it's basically required
because of the problem that we don't know what the user will do later.
So we must implement everything in such a way so that we assume little or nearly none about our input.
Okay, so, and if you think about this,
what this means is that the algebraic operators
defined an abstract logic for processing.
As we say, for example,
towards the left side towards the right side.
So this is very abstract operations.
And everything that is specific to the data item,
like how do we do a comparison?
What is the attribute that I'm interested in?
Also, this is always hidden in these subscripts.
So these small things that are attached to an operator,
that tell me how everything works.
Now in particular, usually we, the operator does not know
the data type or the bite size of the input tuple.
So we have no idea if it's a string or integer.
And the interesting thing is we don't really care.
So we don't have to know if it's a string or an integer,
but only thing that I need is I need a way
to compare two elements, but this I get via a subscript.
So somebody attaches the subscript to my operator.
And then, so I know this is what I do.
By the way, why is the name subscript?
Just think about this, if this here, for example,
this is a select and if I attach here,
this is a typical example of a subscript.
Also the predicate that we want to apply.
But in reality, many operators have a lot of subscripts,
more than what we usually write down
when we by hand draw an algebra tree.
But if, just if you're curious,
you can go to a database tool
For example, if you go to our own system, you can go to either this one, our new project,
ombradb.com, or instead you can go to our previous one, hyperdb.postwork.org.
And so there you can enter a secret query and then you can say explain.
as a plan, please show me the plan, this shows you the algebra plan, but then when you click on it with your mouse,
you get more information, or if you want to see it in full beauty, so in raw form, as human friendly,
you can affect in our these two systems, you can also in the secret query, in the box, you can just say,
explain verbose and then select whatever you want to do, so some query.
And now this is verbose setting here, it will mean that this is not only shows you the operator tree,
but will indeed show you all the subscripts.
So everything is attached to the operators now is shown to you.
So you can see what the system uses.
So we don't know the data type, usually we don't know the size.
We also usually do not understand the content of a tuple.
So am I interested in the first column, in the first attribute, in the second column
attribute, it doesn't really matter.
Because everything that is done with a tuple is hidden in a subscript, so operators themselves
don't care.
So for them the tuple is a black box we just stored.
But the only thing the operator really cares about
is data flow and control flow.
So what do I read and write when and which,
where and when, and which kind of functions
do I have to call in which order?
Okay, everything that is query dependent
is delegated to the subscripts.
So they hide everything here from you
that's consenting query.
And this means of course that our operator implementations
are extremely generic.
Yeah, you can run everything on the intersection.
Because we implement it, our intersection will work all the time.
If you intersect one column, 20,000 columns, it doesn't matter.
Everything will work, because we implement it in a very generic fashion.
There is a small note here at the end of the slide.
You see sometimes, in a few cases, we want to know something about our tuple, because
it allows us to do an easier implementation.
For example, if you would know that my tuple has a fixed size, for example, because there
no string column in there, the fixed size tuples, then we can sometimes implement this
more efficiently. For example, sorting can be done more efficiently if we know that my
elements are fixed size. So therefore we might give the system some information about tuples,
but this is an exception. Usually we don't do this, and also we will always have an
implementation that knows nothing, because you will always need a fully generic version,
and fully generic usually means you know nothing about your data items.
You might have additional implementations that use some knowledge, but your generic
implementation here will really assume very, very little about my data that I want to store.
Now here is an example how you can implement intersects. Now for simplicity, assume
that my input is already sorted, because then it is particularly easy.
So you see my example here is a coil intersect sorted
and I give it three subscripts, namely left, right and compare.
So left is kind of an object that gives me,
or subscripts that gives me the next tuple from the left,
right gives me the next tuple from the right
and compare two values.
So, and now we can implement it like we say,
okay, first we say T1 is the next tuple from left.
So we read the first tuple from the left side.
And then we say, okay, and then N is here next.
that I want to read is the right hand side.
So I read one table from the left
and to remember that the next table to be read
comes from the right.
Okay, then now we have a big loop.
This is as long as my input is not exhausted.
So as long as I'm not done.
So if n is left, then I want to read from the left.
If n is left, then I say t1 is the next table from left,
else t2 is next table from the right.
Okay, now I have two table pointers, t1, t2.
Then I call my compare function.
And remember this is a classical 3-way comparison, so we have never seen this before.
So here we assume that 0 corresponds to equal minus 1, no, so we say we compare A, B, so
So, 0 corresponds to a is equal to b,
minus 1 corresponds to a is less than b,
and 1 corresponds to a is larger than b.
So this is a classical three-way comparison.
And so we call my comparison function,
and now there are three cases.
If c is 0, then both values are the same.
So then we found a value just occurs in both lists.
Therefore, we store t1 as a result.
have stored T2 instead, but because T1 is equal to T2, it doesn't matter. So we can store either T1 or T2.
So in this case, we stay with T1. So else if C1 is zero, so my left side is smaller than my right
side, then I say N is left, so the next tuple should be read from the left, else N is right,
so I read the next tuple from the right, and I repeat. So I do this until I run out of tuples.
Okay, and this is of course, this is simplified because I assume my input is already sorted.
If I would have to sort it is more complicated, but nonetheless, so this is one way in two
elements and note that this implementation here assumes virtually nothing about our tuples.
So is my tuple small or large? Doesn't matter. How many attributes does it have? Doesn't matter.
So what do I do? What is my reason for comparing? Also doesn't matter. My implementation here will
long as left, right and compares provided to me and to what's the name implies.
Okay.
And so the model here is that each operator produces a set or more precisely a back or
even more precisely a data stream of resultables.
Now what I do mean with this distinction here, so the simple relation model is of course
a set, a mathematical set.
And this is true if I have a primary key and in general sense of course we can have it back,
we can have duplicates.
Now, why do we say stream here?
Usually we don't, but in a few cases,
we care about the order of tuples that is produced.
Usually if the user gives me an order by statement.
So if the user says, select star from relation order by x,
then of course I want,
says my result here is order by x.
Therefore, in this case here, I care about the order.
And therefore the model is not a back, but it's a stream.
distinguish the first and the second limit and so on.
Therefore the most general model here is stream of data items.
And each operator here consumes zero or more input sets.
And usually we assume nothing about input.
So we can combine any, so we put anything below here.
So if you put, so example,
if you have a select predicate here, X equals to seven,
it doesn't matter if my input here is a base table like this,
or if my input is another select,
or if my input is a group by instead,
or no sorry, it's a projection,
a group by or join or whatever.
So we assume nothing about my input.
I just want that my input gives me a set
or pack or stream of tablets.
That's it.
It doesn't matter what it is.
And this assumption is that we just read my input,
whatever it is,
allows me to build nearly alterally complex execution plans,
because I can combine them, everything with everything.
So this is of course very good.
This is a very flexible scheme.
Now downside of course is somebody has to implement this.
So now we must make sure that this indeed works,
so that you can plug each operator and each other operator,
so assuming nothing.
And now the interesting question is, how do you do this?
So how should the operator interface look like,
such that you can combine every operator
with every other operator.
And now historically, several different,
several ways have occurred that to do this.
First, now we look at perhaps the simplest,
the simplest of the, I think, how many alternatives?
Three or four alternatives that we will look at here.
So one way to implement the operator interface
is what we call here full materialization.
And so the assumption basically is,
the operator reads zero or more relations as an input
and produces a relations output.
And this interface here takes this in a literal sense.
So like we read base tables as input
and we write a new base table as output.
So we read, of course my data
must be physically stored somewhere,
but so this is my input,
in simple scales an array or something,
it's an input representation.
This is another input representation.
So if I send to a join,
Then I write out a new array, that's it.
And so I read my input completely, I write my output completely, and then the next operator starts.
So full materialization.
Now the advantage of this is, if you do this first, it's pretty easy to implement.
It's a very simple model, because everything is always a materialized table.
So this is good.
What's also good is that you are never surprised by your input.
After all, I read a materialized table as inputs, or multiple materialized tables as input.
So if I could look at them, in particular, I know how large my input is.
This is also good, because then I can react to this.
Just to illustrate this, if you think about a join, and if you say, for example,
we want to build a hash table out of the smaller side, which is usually a good idea.
And if we traditionally, we assume that my left input here is a build side, so that
left side, so then do this R and S. Now if I use the full materialization, note that this here can
of course be a tree, it doesn't have to be a table, like here, this can also be something large,
so it can be a tree. And then of course when I plan, when I construct this algebra expression,
I'm not really sure how large my left side will be. So there are estimates, like I can say,
I predict that my left side contains 100 tuples and my right side contains 20,000 tuples, for
example, then this would make sense.
But this is my prediction and predictions are sometimes wrong, unfortunately.
It's quite difficult to predict the output size for some operators.
Therefore, sometimes I make mistakes.
So I think my left side contains 10 values, but in reality it might contain 50,000.
Of course, it's a large error, but this can occur.
And in the full materialization interface, this is not a problem because my
So, the side will be materialized anyway, so even though it's a subtree like this, we
will nevertheless write this down here into a table R.
So, we store it in the, of course, a temporary table, not a real table, so not something a
user can see.
We construct a temporary table that contains all my values.
And then my join again gets two tables as input.
And therefore, the first thing I will do is, I look at the size of these two tables and
And if I see that, for example,
my right hand side is much smaller than my left hand side,
I just swap the left and right.
Because I can do this with the join.
So I can swap my two sides,
and therefore you are never surprised for your input.
So this is good.
Also what's also good is,
if my input is fully materialized,
some things become pretty simple.
Like if you want to run things in parallel, for example.
So let's make a very simple example here.
We want to say for everything is five,
this is my input.
So if my input is materialized somewhere,
then what I can do is I can just,
this is for example, modulation,
I can just cut it into pieces.
The first thread,
please make the first,
filter the first fragment,
second thread,
filter the second fragment, and so on.
I cut it,
and then it runs parallel,
very easy too.
Okay, not so easy as result construction,
because we have the inverse problem.
But nevertheless, this is pretty easy.
Also, what's also easy is result sharing,
because it could be if multiple queries
that produce the same intermediate result,
at least conceptually,
if you run full materialization,
you can just keep the intermediate result
because you have written it somewhere anyway,
so you can give it to somebody.
Now, so therefore,
this is, these are the strengths of the approach.
Nevertheless, in practice,
this is, even though it's so easy,
and so it also has a lot of problems.
Main problem, of course, is materialization is expensive.
If I take my output of an operator and I write it somewhere,
even if it is main memory,
this writing costs me something.
Now, so because I physically have to write it somewhere
and then read it back again later,
this costs me something and this can be quite expensive.
Even worse, of course,
if the data is larger than main memory,
so if my intermediate size is larger than main memory,
if I have to write all this,
oh my God, this is super expensive.
Now, so to make an example, to illustrate this,
assume we have something like this.
Of course, this is a silly example, but there is less.
I can give you a secret query that triggers it.
So we say, yeah, so we even say, yeah, true.
Well, okay, this is a really silly example.
Okay, well, it's not that silly.
It is a bit less silly example, but no less.
So we can say, let's do A equals B, and we are only a few distinct values for A and B.
equal values and then at the end we do something like a filter here, c equals
seven or so. And note that in the way I have constructed the queries, you cannot merge the
join and the filter because it is in full auto joint, you cannot merge them. Okay, nevertheless,
it could be that this final filter is pretty restrictive, so there will be only few output
tuples, but the full auto joint can produce a very large number of combinations because
There can be many, many combinations,
but only few of them will satisfy the filter.
We can construct these examples.
If you run a full materialization setup here,
we will write everything after the join here
to disk or it leads to memory.
And therefore we write a lot of stuff
that we discard later.
And this is of course not so attractive.
So full materialization, simple, has some advantages,
but overall materialization is too expensive.
There are only a few systems do uses,
most notably Monadib,
our friends from CWI in Amsterdam. So they use this model and but most other people don't and
I think for good reasons. It has some strengths but the price is in my opinion too high usually.
Or to quote Peter Bonshu, who is one of the main developers of Modelway and
And he said the Fulmetrization interface is a forced-gen pact, so pact with the devil.
Meaning it has some attractive properties and you don't want to lose attractive properties
of course.
And now they have built their system, they no longer want to use the strengths of them,
but overall the disadvantages are actually more than the advantages.
So you probably don't want to use Fulmetrization even though it's pretty simple.
Now what else can you do?
So this is option two, it's the iterator model.
So this is the most widely modeled across all systems.
So most database systems, at least the older ones and even some of the newer ones, use
that model here.
So the iterator model.
So the assumption is that each operator here produces a tuppered stream on demand.
So for example, we said everybody here produces a relations output and the model here is that
somewhere but it's just you can iterate over it. So you read it on demand.
And the advantage is now that data is pipelined between operators. Now what does this mean? So we
just pass one tuple around from one operator to the other without making a copy. So when we say
pipelining we mean passing data around and if you ever looked at for example networking interfaces
and operating systems or so you know that for performance reasons they often offer something
that they call zero copy interface,
which means you can send something over the network
without making a copy because copying is expensive.
So with pipelining we mean this,
pass data around from one operator to the other
without making a copy.
And a good thing is now we avoid this unnecessary
materialization that we had in the full materialization
interface because it could be that we are only
interested in one tuple or a few tuples.
So therefore we could stop early,
we don't have to read more complete input,
I just mean the most obvious example, of course,
is somebody in SQL says, select blah, blah, blah,
where x equals to five limit one.
Okay.
As a full materialization model,
at least if you implement it by the book,
you would first filter out everybody who has x equals five,
we would materialize it somewhere,
value from this.
While in the iterator model you would say, hey, I want a one tuple where x equals 5,
and then you actually can stop afterwards.
So that's, you are much more flexible in the control flow.
You can decide if you want to read something or not.
Another advantage is pretty easy to implement the iterator model.
It's a very simple model.
Of course, we will look later at how this is implemented.
Now the disadvantages, usually whenever you want a tuple from an operator, remember that
my input and when I build my database system I have no idea what my input will be
and this means that I call an unknown object and this is usually done with a virtual function call
so I'm not sure if you if you are familiar with how most operate object oriented programming
languages implement polymorphism but what they basically do is instead of saying a call function
So instead of saying call function next,
so they give me the next value.
So because this, so if I would know my input is,
for example, selection, I could say select next,
but because I don't know if my input is a select or not,
could be anything.
Therefore, so usually I have an object.
This object contains a pointer to a table,
and in this table here,
we store all virtual functions that this exposes,
including for example, next.
Therefore, if I want to call this function now,
I look at my object,
I retrieve the pointer to the table,
I look at the table,
I retrieve the pointer to the function,
and then I do the call.
Yeah, and this means I do more memory access
and I'll have more interactions,
and this is usually slower.
So a call to a virtual function is a bit,
it's not super slow,
but it's a bit slower than a regular function call.
And I will do this for every tupper
pass between operators,
and this tend to be millions of tuples.
Therefore, if you do something that's a bit more expensive,
a million times, this is not so super attractive.
And so performance is not ideal in the iterator model.
Related to this, it's an iterator model
has a poor locality.
Why do we, what do we mean with poor locality?
Like if, remember we read always one tuple here.
So if you have to do something like this,
so then I do a join,
and of course could be a larger chain, but I just assume this. So I've said here this join, it says
okay, I need to tuple from my left side. So you ask the select give me tuples and you ask the
relation give me tuples. So basically your control floor bounces down and up. So you go across a lot
of operators until you get your tuples. So this means you have poor localities, you are looking
at many parts of the code at the same time and your CPU doesn't like this. So your CPU wants
that you look at a small tight loop.
So this is when performance is best.
If your code execution goes all over your place
in the code, then this will be slower typically.
Because you might have get instruction case misses.
You probably lose register content.
You cannot keep everything in registers.
And so therefore this locality is important
for good performance.
We also look at this later, a bit later.
Okay, now I've already sketched a bit
how the iterator model works.
we say we retrieve one tuple at a time.
So now we look at this a bit more closely.
So the traditional interface
for the iterator model here is like this.
We offer each object that we have,
so each original operative operator
offers three methods, open, next, close.
And they do what the name implies.
So when we call open an operator that says,
please prepare for execution.
So please allocate memory, open files,
or whatever you have to do.
So please prepare so that we can start executing.
So then afterwards we call next.
So, and we do this not only once, but a lot of times.
So next says, please give me the next tuple.
And maybe we will talk about implementation next
in one of few slides, but more conceptually,
it just says here is a tuple or it says,
I'm out of tuples.
So then you know that you're done.
So this is the iterator call here.
So this here iterates over the output.
And so we always get the next type from our output.
And so when we're done, of course we can call it close.
And this means please release memory, close files, whatever, so that you are done processing.
Again, the good thing about this is this is a very simple model.
Now three functions, open, next, close, and we can handle really, really complicated queries
with such simple interfaces.
It is actually surprising when you see this the first time.
Now the price you pay for this means the interface to the outside is simple, but the implementation
of operators is often not that simple
because you have to maintain a complex state.
Remember that next gives me the next tuple,
but I can be in the middle of some very complicated stuff,
but I must now stop, produce one tuple,
and then continue when the next code comes.
So state maintenance is the main problem
of the operator interface.
You will see this when we implement this.
So the code, even though conceptually
the interface is very simple,
the code you have to write is often not that simple.
This is a price you have to pay.
This also brings poor performance,
because usually complex code is slow.
Maybe not always, but usually simpler code is better.
If it asymptotically behaves the same,
then simpler code is usually better.
Okay, and now, so this is what I meant.
So what's concerning the interface?
Now, how do we really pass the operators?
Because here we say, next, give me the next tupper.
So next says, okay, please give me whatever.
In particular, remember that we have no idea what the data is.
So the operator has no data types, we don't know how many attributes we have, therefore
we cannot just pass the tuple around itself, at least not easily.
Strictly speaking we could, but there is no obvious or easy way to pass the tuple around
because of these unknown properties of my query.
So therefore there are, probably more than two, but at least two common ways to do this.
First way is to say, okay, I cannot pass the tuple around easily, but what I can pass around
easily is a pointer to the tuple.
So if I have a table scan R and then this is my page and this here are all my records
here on my page.
And then if you call next on this table scan, the first next call will give you a pointer
to that element, the next next call will give you a pointer to that element and then the
The next call will return null, meaning we are out of tuples, so we have no further values.
And the data itself is not copied, but instead is left on the page or in the buffer, wherever
your data is stored.
So we just return a pointer to my data.
So this is of course an elegant model, so cheap.
Just computer pointer, pass it around.
So the downside of this approach is, what do you do if you have computed columns?
When I was a computed column, it is a user free to write for example, you can formulate
in SQL, select 4 times x plus y or something like this or arbitrary complicated stuff.
And this here is a new value that does not exist in your physical type of code because
it on the fly and this is what we call a computed column yes computed column now if we just output
this to the user this doesn't really matter because we just print it so that's okay but note
that this here can be a sub query somewhere deep in our query tree so there could be something higher
up again to select blah blah blah yeah so this sub this computer column could be in the middle
a query somewhere and then we need a way to pass this new column up to our outer part of the query.
And how should we do this? Because we cannot just point to the table because the values are not
stored on a page. Now of course what we could do is we could make a copy of the table and then copy
out everything including the new column, but then it's no longer that elegant and that cheap.
Computer columns are a weakness of the first approach. The first approach is pass the point
to the tuple. The second approach is actually better, but a bit more difficult to understand.
Namely, when you say how do you give me tuple, the answer is not at all.
So now what does this mean? So in this world here, the interface of my next function here is usually
tuple pointer, tuple pointer next,
and that gives you a pointer to the tuple. So the alternative two is to say,
anything, I just return a bool.
Do I have a new tuple or not?
So if I return true, then there is a new tuple.
If I return false, then there is no new tuple.
Okay, by then you can ask yourself,
if this is my model,
how do I access my content of my tuple?
Because the operator, my shell operator,
my input operator says here is a new tuple,
So it just says true, here's the tuple.
But how do I find it?
And the answer is, I store all the ways of my tuple
in a global data space.
Traditionally, this is called a register.
There's not, now, if you're honest,
it's not a real register, not like a CPU register,
because it's all done in software.
Now, but nevertheless, so the database
has a piece of memory reserved.
So we allocate this once.
And then we say, for example,
this part of my memory is reserved
root x and this part of my memory is reserved towards root y and then I might of course
have other attributes too, a, b.
So this is allocated and is static and now when I say static usually I mean it will be
a thread local so each thread will have it.
Sometimes you also want to have really global values but at least for our purposes here we
can say each thread has its own so usually we have such a copy.
And now if you call from your input, if you call, just say let's ignore the threading problem,
so assume for a moment we are running single thread, so not parallelism, then we have just
one set of registers here, so this rectangle is my set of registers, and now if for example
my, this is my relation r, and then here comes my predicate that says x equals to 5, and
then in the end I want the output for example y.
So then the projection here calls next, yeah next.
Says the select please give me tuple.
Then the select says next to my input here please give me tuple.
Then the relation looks at this content and retrieves the first tuple, for example x4,
y11, a and b, I just ignore them, I don't write anything here.
So then it says, relation R, it says true.
Here is the tuple.
Then my filter protocol checks the content of the X field, says, oh no, this is not equal to 5.
So please give me a new value.
So then again we call next.
Then R reloads a new value into the register file here.
So we now overwrite this.
So instead of writing here 411, say 5 and 20.
again the answer is true, there is a new tuple, then the select suddenly found a match, so now
we return true too, okay, and then the select looks into the y field, sees the 20, now we can
print the 20. So this is how it is. So if you look at the operator interface itself, so if it's just
an interface of next, then we don't really see the tuple because we just return true or false.
the tuple in reality is passed as a side effect of the update to the global data space,
so to the myRegister file.
And the beauty of this approach is that the subscripts all operate on the registers, like
this x equals 5, so this of course is the subscript here.
So this operates on the registers and looks into my registers, but the operator themselves
doesn't care.
The operator itself never touches this register file because we don't need it.
I just know if somebody returns me true,
I know that the correct value has been loaded into the registers
and then I can call my subscripts and this will look at the register file.
The operator itself doesn't care.
Okay, and this is actually the superior interface for the operator interface.
So if you do it like this, so then it can be very generic.
Now, computed columns are not a problem.
So if somebody computes a new value,
we just create a new field here, computed column,
Then here inside we write here 1, 2, 3 or whatever is computed so we can update this
over as we need it.
So computer columns are no problem.
We can just store them as they are.
Okay, sorry, there are just one more comments we said we have open next close.
Just for completeness, I know at least two systems that change the interface slightly.
I've just mentioned this, this is not a very mainstream solution, but some people do this.
So I put this here in brackets, so don't, don't, I said most people don't, but it makes
sense to do this.
You might want to add another function, namely first.
So and why would you care about first?
Because when we come to the real implementations of operators, you see that very often the
differently from all subsequent tuples. Why? Because a lot of work is probably
done until the first tuple can be produced, like we might build a hash table
or do some very complicated stuff, and this only affects the very first tuple.
And therefore it makes sense to have a separate function in the first. Of
course, strictly speaking, you don't need this, because we can easily
emulate the first with next, because one way to implement this is to say
bool next, then we can of course implement it like this.
If first call, then we say first call is false, so we say this is initially true, first call
is false.
and then we do whatever we have to do and then we continue with regular processing
yeah so therefore we don't really need a first interface yeah but of course the downside is
then now we have an if here in my hot pass because you have to realize this call to next here
this is super hot you call next for every type of that we process
This can be many many millions, which means we introduce many million additional ifs.
Of course now on modern machines it's not that bad as it used to be, of course modern
machines will produce branch prediction, and we say this if will probably nearly always
be false.
So therefore on today's machines it's not that bad.
But in the past this if here became noticeable in some cases, and therefore people said okay
let's do a dedicated first function so that we only do this expensive stuff in the first call
and everything else is cheap. Indeed I saw this improved performance a bit,
but probably today it's not that worthwhile.
Okay so this was the first two interfaces, first full materialization, second iteration.
Full materialization is very expensive, iteration is very flexible but also quite expensive because
they have so many calls. First one is expensive because we copy everything, the second one is
so expensive because we have so many calls. Now a compromise between these two is the third one,
here is the blockwise processing. So at first glance it is quite similar to the iterator model,
like we iterate over a tuppled stream as before. But the difference is we don't do this tuppled
But instead we do this in streams of larger chunks.
So basically the difference between calling next for each tuple or give me the next thousand
or so.
So just as in the iterator model we do function coil, say please give me something, but instead
of asking for one value we ask for many values.
Now, let's for example, a thousand.
And then of course this call overhead is hidden.
Because if we adjust by this change,
I reduce the number of calls by a factor of a thousand.
Therefore now this is of course,
then you don't see this anymore.
If you do a call for every tuple,
this actually is expensive.
But if you do a call for every thousand tuples,
ah, this is unnoticeable.
So this is okay.
So the block-wise processing is much, much cheaper.
Yeah, so this, we have far fewer function calls.
data, code and data locality.
Why code and data locality?
Because we no longer output one tuple, but we output many tuples.
Just think about the example that I had drawn.
So for this one here, so for the basic iterator model, for every single tuple we jump from
join to select to base table and back to select and back to join.
And also for each single tuple we involve three operators.
While in the blockwise model here we would say auto-slut with the join of course, but
then we would say hey give me a thousand here and then this case would do nothing because
thus ask my input give me a thousand.
Now my scan here would scan over my input and output 1000 tuples.
And this of course in a tight loop, so because now we would do a for loop, for and so on
yeah so over 1000 values so we have now a loop and cpus like loops.
So a tight loop of data is good.
Loop over 1000 values.
Then we output it, set my 1000 values here to the select.
The select now checks 1000 filter conditions, again in the loop, as we do another for loop here.
For the 1000 filter conditions.
And then we output the 1000 to the join.
So we have much better locality, we don't jump from one place to the other.
Now a disadvantage of course is we have additional materialization overhead.
In the simple iterator model we could often, may not always, but we could always pipeline
values which means we just pass them around without making any copies.
Here because we output 1000 values so we can no longer keep them for example in my global
register file because I can keep one tuple in there but I cannot keep 1000 tuples in
there.
Therefore we must now make a copy of the tuple and must store it somewhere.
just like the full materialization interface.
Now you could ask yourself, isn't this just like full materialization?
Because full materialization also does this.
We also get good locality and also materializes and also fewer calls.
Now the big advantage of this model here is that you will choose a block size that fits
into your cache.
Now so remember that your L1 cache, the fastest cache on your CPU, is usually something like
32 KB.
So therefore if I ask for a thousand values and if my values are not too large, there
is in fact a decent chance that this will fit in the L1 cache, which would of course
would be very very fast.
This is best.
Now if perhaps I cannot do this, this might be too small, it might be larger than 32 KB,
It's probably 512 kB or even more, depending on your CPU, or even more.
And therefore if I choose a block size such that my tupper values fit here, then I can
still keep it in a cache a bit slower than I want, but nevertheless we can keep it in
cache and I can just read it back.
But with full materialization my data is most likely larger than my cache.
So therefore with full materialization I have to go to memory, and memory is pretty slow
It is not too much slow, but if you compare to a CPU cache, it is slow.
Your memory is much slower than your CPU cache.
In this block-wise processing here, if you choose my block size carefully,
then my tupples will reside in the CPU cache, and therefore it will be cheap actually.
Materialization overhead is there, yes, but it will be lower than in the full materialization
due to caching.
Now, but nevertheless, a disadvantage here is even if I don't have to pay the high price,
this nevertheless consumes memory bandwidth, in particular due to this writing.
And so the problem is I write it in a vector and I know my vector is in cache because I
want to read it back.
What I cannot tell the CPU, at least not easily, is to say, okay, somebody wants to read it
Actually, I want to read it from a cache, but nobody else has to see it.
Note that most modern CPUs here are many core or multi core at least, so there is more than one.
Therefore, the buffer here that I use to store my tupples, this of course sits somewhere in memory.
So this is my total memory.
Somewhere in here will be my buffer where I store my type of values, for example 1000
here.
And of course I want that this buffer here is in my CPU cache.
Because if it is in cache, the first if I do something like this, then the scan here
will put it into my buffer and then the filter will take it out of the buffer again.
And if the buffer is in cache, then this is reasonably cheap.
So this is the idea.
Problem is, the CPU does not understand this.
This is our goal.
So our goal is just to pass data from one part of my own code to another part, and other
threads, so some different parts of my program, don't care about this buffer, because this
buffer is only from a current thread.
But I cannot trade this to my system, unfortunately, and therefore the system will, even though
it keeps it in cache, it will at some point flush this out to memory, because we must
make sure that if somebody else tries to read this, then it gets the data.
Even though in many cases we could say, I have read it already, you can discard it.
But this we cannot say easily.
Therefore, this bufferinger consumes memory bandwidth even though we aim to be in cache.
That is bad.
Now the disadvantage is we are less flexible in the control flow.
In the iterator model we could read one tuple from any of our inputs.
Here we can only read larger chunks of data which is problematic for some operators.
But usually this is a minor problem.
So control flow is usually good enough.
There are a few operators that have problems with this, notably merge join.
So for merge join this is not ideal, but for all other operators it doesn't really matter.
So the less flexible control flow is usually okay.
But additionally, the maturization overhead is a problem.
It is less than in the first option, but nevertheless, this is indeed somewhat of a
problem.
So now, therefore we now look at the fourth option and this does something quite different
from the other ones.
Namely, so previously everybody basically pulled its input.
So if you think about the iterator model, it's the most visible, so if you just say
join, then select, and then a relation, and then we have another relation,
my model was here, this here says please give me a tuple, please give me a tuple,
please give me a tuple, until here, and then it says here, here is a tuple, and so on.
And so this was if we pull a tuple up, so we say give me one tuple.
And in this model here we reverse the direction, we say no, no, we don't pull tuples up,
Instead, we push tuples.
So we would say the relation R starts and says, hey, here's a tuple, please take this.
Then the select gets it and says, okay, perhaps it's okay.
And then we start into my drawing.
And then comes the next tuple, and the next tuple, and the next tuple.
So instead of pulling it up, we push it from bottom to top.
Ok, and now if you think about what this means in code, we see code examples later in the
lecture, but what this means in code is that here in R we will have a loop, a small loop,
the loops are a bunch of data and then retrieves all tuppets.
And usually most of the logic in our query plan is executed in a few loops where then
the data is passed up.
And loops are good.
So small tied loops is something that our CPU likes, therefore performance-wise is a
good idea.
We also get good code on data locality because we run a lot of code in R and only for when
we have values we might sometimes call the select and even more rarely call the join.
So we have most of our execution here is spent within R and we don't go out of R. So we stick
in there.
That gives me good locality.
Basically just like in the HL model we can still pipeline so we don't have to make a
copy because I can, if you think about the register file here, R can load the values
in the register file, then this here can take the values out of the register file, this
is the same so we can just pipeline it without making a copy.
Now that I mentioned this, perhaps to illustrate this, what does this mean with pipeline, let's
make it a bit more silly.
Let's look at this.
Let's assume we have a scan.
Filter, filter, filter, filter, and so on.
Oops, and so on.
Many filters.
Now, if you want to understand pipelining, just look at the left side of this join.
Here comes a tuple.
Just think about how many copies of these tuples do we make.
In a pipelining approach we don't make any.
Or perhaps, of course, if you're picky, we could say we make one because we load the
value from our page and then we store it probably in the register file, which is of course,
is a kind of a copy, if you wish.
So we, depends on how it's implemented, but we might copy it somewhere once.
Okay.
But then it doesn't matter if you have here between six filters or if you have 20,000
filters, no further copy of the table is made.
it sits in this register file and can still set all the time.
We check additional conditions until we hit the join, then of course we do something with the tuple.
But the number of selections in between the scan and the join does not affect the number of copies.
This is a pipelining approach.
But if you are in full materialization or even in the block-wise processing,
we would make a copy of all the tuples,
then we would make a filter, we make another copy, we pass it to the next filter, makes
another copy and so on.
Here we would copy all the time.
And in the blockwise we do it in less severe form, but nevertheless we have a deep cascade
of operators where we also tend to make a lot of copies.
In the push model we have pushed data up, we don't have to make a copy.
Another interesting advantage is that if in this pushing here we can in fact support deck-structured plans.
Now what is a deck-structured plan?
Assume we have something like this, so we have a complicated expression,
so some subtree, then we do for example a group wire or some other processing,
and then we might have something like this.
Okay, of course, a constructed example, but nevertheless, so this is no longer a tree,
because this grouper here has two parent nodes, this is not a tree, but this is a deck, a
deck is a directed astrograph, so of course, these edges have a direction, and so a directed
astrograph, this graph here has no cycle, if you direct them, you can direct them, for
them up or down, it doesn't really matter, we just have to fixate it.
Let's say we point down, so then we point like this.
And so this is my plan, this contains no cycles, so this is a directed astroclical graph.
But nevertheless, we have nodes with more than one incoming edge, so it's not a tree.
Okay, and the advantage of this is if this computation in the middle here is expensive,
If you compute this once, then when we have a tuple, so it is produced here, then it is
pushed up, so we take the tuple, push it up, push it through the group by, and then we
can pass it to both this and that operator.
So two operators can consume a tuple, or in fact an arbitrary number of operators can
consume a tuple.
This would not work in the iterator model.
Because in the iterator model what would happen is, you would call next here, you would call
next here, then you get the tuple, then you would call next here, and the next value that
you get when you come from the left side is now taken away, such that the call from the right
side will become later, so of course later we will also call here, so when you come from the right
side the tuple is gone. So both operators would take away tuples from each other, maybe because
you always iterate over the stream, therefore if left fetches the tuple, right doesn't get it.
That of course is bad.
We don't want this.
Therefore in the iterator model we usually do not allow DEC structure plans.
We sometimes allow it if we are sure that the nodes that contain multiple patterns is full materialization.
If you make a copy of my output then I can read it multiple times because the tople is not gone when I read it.
Full materialization allows me to share even with the iterator model.
But here in this push model we can share
Tuples between subtrees without any restrictions. Yes, we can just
Shouldn't say without there a few restrictions, but it isn't this this scenario. There are no problems. We can easily pass it to
Ten parent operators knows no different than passing it to one. So this is good
Now I was a what are the disadvantage of this this model here? I first we are more restricted on our control flow
because if my data comes from from my
a child to me, so I can not easily say,
oh, I want to get one value from the left
and then one value from the right.
This doesn't work.
Because in the push model,
R gives you all its data,
and then S gives you all its data.
You cannot say, I need one value from R
and one value from S,
and then again one from R,
then again one from S,
you're alternating between left and right,
which you can easily do in the iterator model,
but you cannot do this in this push model.
So the control flow is more restricted.
On the other hand, this is nearly never a problem.
So the only operator that matters here is the sort merge join.
So we take two sorted inputs and we want to intersect them.
There you want to alternate between reading left and right.
But this is the only one.
And you can work around this problem by materializing one of the sides.
So if you make a copy of one of the two sides, the smaller one, of course, you prefer to
make a copy of the smaller one, then you can handle this even in the push model here.
The second disadvantage is code generation is more involved, but on the other hand, I
mean you implement this only once, so who cares if it is a bit more difficult.
This is not a real disadvantage.
But the great advantage is that it gives you much better code.
And also, if we look in the lecture later at implementation, I mean code generation
might be more involved, but in general the operators are, if you ask me, easier to implement
in this model than in the iterator model for example.
So now let's to illustrate this, let's implement three very very very simple operators in all
models so that you can compare them easily. So we just implement a scan, so read a whole relation,
we implement select, so read a relation and output all tuples that satisfy a predicate,
and we implement cross, so cross product between two relations.
Of course in reality we want to have a join, but we just want to compare approaches here,
we make it, keep it simple, so we just do a cross product. It's a very simple one.
Now in the full mutualization model, I said the advantage here that this is quite simple,
this is what you see here, all three operators fit on a single slide.
This will not be the case for the other approaches, they are more difficult,
But this one here we can easily implement on single-size
because it's so simple.
So let's start with this scan here.
The scan actually does nothing.
And because we are supposed to scan the relation R
and we just say, hey, my data is stored in R.
And so I do nothing.
I just return a reference to my relation
because it is already materialized.
Now our next operator here, select.
So I want to read, find everything from my input
where a certain predicate is true.
How do I do this?
I create a new relation,
a new temporary relation,
not visible to the user,
but nevertheless, we need some space
where we can store stuff.
So we create a new relation R' here,
so we can store my data.
Then in this line here,
I loop over all tuples in R,
I check if my predicates true,
and if yes, I store the tuple in R'.
Okay, so this is what we do here.
And afterwards, I return R' saying,
okay, my data is now in R'.
Also pretty simple.
This is the advantage of course,
to a new relation. And then the cross product, I get two relations R1 and R2 as input. I'm supposed
to output the cross product between them. How do I do this? I again allocate a new relation R'
then here I loop over all values from R1, I loop over all values from R2, I combine them and store
them in R'. Sorry, I messed this up here. I store them in R'. Very simple implementation
And so we can, of course, we, in particular this step here is expensive,
because we now create a really large output relation.
So it's very expensive, but it's very easy.
Okay, now let's look at the iterator model.
You see the iterator model is more complicated.
We can no longer fit it on a single slide.
Now, so now I have to show you this piece by piece.
and we start with the scan which is a very simple operator of course
and we look here at the two functions open next and because at least in the
pseudo code we show here the close does nothing is so close we can leave out
because we so we abstract away here so many details but so conceptually what we do is when
we call open so somebody calls us open and we are supposed to open the relation r what we do is we
I want to read r probably in this point in time I'm loading a page in the buffer manager so but
here we don't talk about it just say remember that I want to read r I say my current position
here zero and I say I want to stop when I when I hit the size of r and so this is my end condition
okay open still pretty easy then the next coil and remember that we want to iterate over my
output here when we call next. So then the next is the following, did I already reach the end?
So if my current is my current tuple id greater or equal to the limit, if yes we say for there is no further tuple.
So we just say no there is nothing, otherwise we load the tuple t from in at position t id.
So this of course I now must store somewhere in my global register file. So I load the tuple, store it,
then i increase my tuple ID by one and then i return true so i say okay here i have one
one more tuple and of course you cannot call next repeatedly until it returns false and then when
you get false and you know okay i have seen all my tuples okay so this is also pretty simple
select is also not too difficult so when we can be called open on a select we just remember okay
what is my input and what is my predicate? Oh no, here we don't do anything, of course,
depends on how you implement it, but perhaps we should at this point here call
in.open because probably we want to recursively open my input. Of course, it could be,
it depends on how you implement it, it could be that you trigger the open call for all operators
at the same time by just looping over the list of operators, then of course you don't do this.
then this implementation is okay if you want to recurse and be here we would call open on my input
okay so the open prepares operator for execution then when we call next yes i please give me the
next tuple then we say as long as my input here is not exhausted oh by the way it's a copy and
paste error here because we don't the select effect gets no argument and so we don't need
any arguments we have stored the arguments in my operator here so we call the next function
give this give me the next tuple then i take my input and ask me in plus give me a tuple
and if the input says yes then i call the predicate and if the predicate also says yes then i return
true otherwise i continue looping here so i say give me the next tuple next tuple next tuple next
tuple so i call next all the time and at some point the next of course will return false saying
my input is exhausted and then I leave the loop and also myself return false and say okay
no further tablets I'm done okay and note that we cannot ignore this loop
so we could let's say say okay let's comment this out so we just say a or no perhaps not comment
this out we could let by the way what I'm writing now is wrong so don't take notes just to illustrate
this you could think that you can implement it like if not in dot next return
false
then we check a predicate if it's true return true as well as return false
this you could think that you should implement this but of course you must not because it could
be that we get one table that doesn't satisfy the bracket but the next table would yeah and but we
not allowed to return false in this case because otherwise my parent will stop asking me for
tupples. So they only ask me as long as I return true, therefore I must need a loop here, so from
here to here. So as long as my input still gives me a tupple, I check the predicate, if it's true,
I continue, otherwise I stop. Okay, this is still not very complicated, what is complicated is this
one here, across products. So if you think back in the full immortalization model, this was I think
Here we already start writing more and it is still simplified and squeezed on a slide here.
So even a simple cross product is quite involved in the iterator model and other real joints
are even worse.
And so the problem here is that we have to keep state because we are only allowed to
output one tuple, therefore I must remember where I am and so this requires some bookkeeping.
So therefore here my state here is left, right and step.
So when I have a call to open, I should open this, I store.
Okay, what is my left side, what is my right side and I set step to true initially.
Now we come to the core of the algorithm here, the next call.
So then we again need a loop.
So while true, so infinite loop.
So then we ask ourselves, is step true?
So like we did in the beginning, or perhaps another name for step.
So step means read from left.
This is perhaps an explanation.
So when I said step true, it means I have to read the left side.
So is step true true?
So then I load the next type from my left side.
If there is no table from the left side then I said okay I am done, I can no longer find
anything.
Otherwise if there is a table from the left side I restart the right side, remember that
we have to read the right side repeatedly for every table from the left, therefore I
call here open on my right side saying please rewind yourself I want to read again.
And then in the next line I clear the step flag and say I no longer want to read from
the left.
Okay then I have a value from the left.
Then I read the next value from the right.
If I get one then I return true saying okay I have a match.
Of course this means that we stop at this point.
So we read one from the left, we read one from the right then we stop.
Later we will be called back again and then of course we must remember what we did.
Namely we must remember that we have already read from the left side.
We remember this step flag here.
Step flag is clear.
So then we read the next table, next table, next table, next table and so on.
says, oh, I have no further tupples.
Then we set step to true,
and then the loop here continues,
reads the next tupple from the left.
If there's none tupple, I stop, otherwise, and so on.
Okay, and this is already a bit more involved,
even though we just did a silly cross product.
I mean, cross product is the most primitive binary operator
that you can imagine.
If you implement a real operator, like a join,
then this bookkeeping, like remembering where am I,
what have to do next, can become quite complicated.
Now, so the iterator model from the outside looks simple, but the implementation is not
so simple.
Okay, now also interesting is this one here, the block-wise processing.
Here I assume that I will output 1000 tuples, at most, of course it could be that I have
less than 1000 tuples, but I want to output 1000 tuples.
So therefore, open just looks like in the iterator model, so I store the relation, I say tuple
limit to such relations just as before. Now interesting here is the next call
in the scan. So here c is the size of my chunk here and I say okay how many
tuples do I output? I output a thousand tuples or the distance between limit and
my corner tuple id whatever is smaller because it could be that of course that I have less than a
thousand tuples left. So I check how much tuples do I have left if there are more
thousand tuples and output a thousand otherwise it takes the rest. Okay then I construct an output
array here r' of size c. Of course I mean I write it here because it's easier to formally like this
construct a tuple array. In reality of course you will reuse the memory. So you will not allocate
a new tuple all the time. But because my buffer size is fixed so I will output a thousand values
I will usually have a pre-allocated buffer that I use all the time.
Then I loop here a small loop, remember that for performance reasons loops are good, so
this is good here.
You have a loop over from 0 to c-1, then I load the tuples from in at position tupler
d plus i to r'i.
So I take, so this looks now looks at the number of tuples.
We load all the tuples and we store them in my array.
Then I increase my tuple id not by one but instead by c because this is the number of
tuples that we have processed.
And then I return r' Okay.
So this is one block of data, a thousand values.
And again, the thousand here will be chosen such that this block array here can fit in
cache because this is important.
Now what about select?
So you know the select here looks interesting, open of course is as usual, so we just say
when we open we just remember what's my input, what's my predicate.
Then when we come to the next call, don't take this one here, go by paste arrow, so
Now I am supposed to output 1000 matching values, or at most, I can output less, but
at most 1000 values.
And again I need a for loop here to make sure that I do find them, because it could be that
I will not find any matches in my next block, so I must do this repeatedly.
So this will repeat until we find a match.
Then here I ask my input, please give me a block of tuppets.
Now it could be that there is no further topic because I have read my input completely, therefore then I stop.
This is what I do here, so I check does my input give me an empty block.
If yes I just output the empty block because there is nothing to be gained, then we are done.
Otherwise now I have a block of values and I only want to keep the values where the predicates true.
And this is done here in a funny way, namely in this range here.
So now how do we do this? Now first let me write this differently, just to make it easier
to understand. But this is what I will write now, conceptually the same but is less efficient.
So we could implement, so this block, so this was in squares, we could implement,
And let's draw an arrow here.
This here corresponds to, of course it is a different implementation, but it corresponds
to.
I set my right pointer to zero.
Then I do just the same for loop.
I say 4i is equal to zero up to r' minus one.
So I loop over all elements.
Then I say, if, I check the predicate, if P of r'i is true, then I say r'w is equal
to r'i w is equal to w plus one okay so this would be probably what you would have written
yeah so this is a more intuitive way i loop over all elements in my block i check if the
predict is true if yes i copy it to the beginning of the block so i have a right pointer perhaps
yeah i should have perhaps explained it more clearly so if this is my block that i get from
input. Could be that I have a match here, I have a match here, I have a match here, but I have
non-matches in between. So what I want, I want to output my parent blocks and contains only matches.
Therefore what I do is I copy this here to the beginning. So I have a bright pointer.
So bright pointer is here initially. Yeah, I write it here, then I increase it to the next position.
Then I copy that value to this position, again I increase the right pointer, and I copy that
value to this position.
You cannot read it anymore unfortunately, but trust me the result is at the end I have
all matches in the beginning and then just some garbage that I don't care for at the
end.
This is the result of the loop.
What will come next here in the code is we set the length of our prime to my right pointer,
which means I truncate my vector here, so I forget everything except matches.
Therefore now my block only contains matches.
Okay, and then just to finish the pseudo code, the very, the very last check here is,
if my block is empty, because it could be that I found no match.
And then I'm not allowed to output this to my parent, because if I output an empty block,
this means that I'm done, but I only want to output non-empty blocks.
Therefore check if the size is larger than zero, then I output the block.
Otherwise my loop continues and I have it on the next block.
Okay, but now coming back to these square parts.
So as I said, this copies all matches to the beginning, but it does it in a very funny
way.
Now, how does this here operate?
Just again, we're looking at this one.
So I have a vector of entries and my i-value here scans over the whole range.
So this is everything and my i-value loops from the beginning to the end.
My w value, this is the write position, so this starts in the beginning, we set it to zero initially.
So now what we do here, so here we copy my read position to my write position.
Note that initially read position and write position are the same,
and that also makes no difference, we just copy the value to the write position,
and the write position is where the next match should be.
Now I want to check if my predicate was true,
and if yes, I want to keep the value, otherwise I want to ignore it, I want to overwrite it.
And this is what this line here does. So here we check the predicate,
and of course this returns true if the predicate is true and zero, sorry, and void if the predicate is wrong.
Now the interesting thing is that in programming languages like C or C++,
true corresponds to one and void corresponds to zero.
Therefore if the predicate is false, I do not increase the right pointer.
The right pointer stays the same because I say right pointer is right pointer plus zero.
The right pointer keeps the same. So therefore if the value a is written here,
and the right pointer is not increased, and afterwards comes b, then a will be overwritten by b.
Now, while if the predicate is true, so let's say we have values abc that we want to store.
So it's here for this one here p is true,
with this one p is false.
Okay, therefore we first copy a,
then we copy b and we overwrite the position because the predicate was false.
Then for b the predicate is true,
therefore the right pointer is increased because a true corresponds to one.
So I increase the right pointer by one, therefore the c now is copied here and so on.
And so whenever a predicate is true,
we advance the right pointer which means that the value will not be overwritten.
If the predicate is false, we keep the right pointer and the predicate is not overwritten.
Okay, now I hope this convinced you that the behavior is correct.
So at the end we have all the values that we want to get.
Now you could ask yourself why did you do this?
So this is what some people here call predicated execution because there is no if here.
We do execute unconditionally.
Instead, we change my pointers and my values depending on the predicate, but not with an
if, just with an arithmetic.
So now, why do we do this?
We do this because CPUs, mean modern CPUs, are out of order execution engines, which
means they do not execute one statement after the other.
Instead, what they do is they execute multiple statements simultaneously, or at least they
tried to do this.
simultaneously but they have a problem when they come to an if because here
let's say here are statements I can execute many of them not all but many of
them simultaneously then comes an if so if then I take here otherwise
so now the CPU has a problem because this if you are most likely depends on
something that you have computed here and because we do execute multiple
but simultaneously this computation is not done yet.
Therefore, I don't know if the predicate is true or false.
I mean, I will know it soon, of course,
but because executing statement takes a moment,
so I currently, I don't know this.
Therefore, what the CPU will do, it will guess.
It will, for example, say, you know what,
in the last 20 loops,
the predicate is always true.
So most likely it will be true now too.
So it will guess.
So now if we're starting executing this part here,
Now, and if this guess was correct, then everything is fine.
So then everything is executed as it is.
So then everything is good, everything is fast.
But if the guess was false, so I started executing this part here, even though I should not have.
Because in reality, I should have executed a different branch, but I didn't know this.
So this is called a branch misprediction.
So I predicted, it takes a true branch, but in reality, it should have taken a false branch.
I must undo everything that my tentative operations are doing.
And I must stop the in-flight pipeline here, that is, of instruction, that is in this part.
So I must basically cancel everything from this block here.
And this is quite expensive.
So a branch miss, so that the CPU is forced to undo its guesses, is an expensive operation,
very expensive.
And this means that if, some people just plot saying here, so how long does a predicate
take?
So a select predicate.
So how long does it take? Depending on the selectivity, also depending on the probability
that p is true. So this is zero means p is always false, this is one means p is always true.
Okay and this here, this is the second axis here is time.
Okay and this here is probability of p.
Oops, sorry, of p.
So what you observe is, if p is always false,
then the if is fast.
Yeah, but the more likely it is that p is true,
the more expensive operation becomes.
So then here's 50%.
And then this is the worst, then it becomes,
I should draw it carefully.
So this is roughly how it looks like.
If my product is nearly always false, then the save is okay.
The CPU will predict correctly that it is not taken, that is okay.
But the more likely it becomes that if it will be taken, the more often the CPU has flushed
its pipeline and undo all the changes.
The expensive.
Worst case, if it is always the 50-50 chance, basically.
Because then you have no idea, you can just guess.
If there is a 50-50 chance of a branch being taken, this is the most expensive case.
always taken is also okay.
So if the P is always true or always false,
it's okay because then we can predict
which we should do and then it becomes cheaper.
Now, if we instead do this one here,
there we don't need any branch prediction
because there's no if here.
Do some automatic, but there's no if.
And this means for that variance,
usually the executioner looks like this.
So it's a flat line.
Now I didn't draw this to scale, admittedly.
So what usually happens is predicated execution is small bits, tiny more expensive than a branch,
if the branch is nearly never or nearly always taken.
Then predicated will be slightly more expensive, usually.
But the moment that we leave the extremes and that sometimes it's true or sometimes
then it is much cheaper to use predicate execution
because there are no branch misses.
So we don't mispredict the branch
because there is no branch.
This of course is a bit advanced way
to implement a predicate,
but this is a very good idea.
So this predicate execution will very often
be much more efficient than if you would have done an if.
Okay, and now for completeness,
we also do a cross product.
You see already that the cross product
does not even fit on a single page.
Now we must be single slides and now we need two slides, because it's not so easy to do.
As in the block was processing, also you see that we have a lot of variables here, so we
have a lot of states that we must store.
So this is of course our input left and right, but then we have a lot of variables that explain
in a moment what to do.
So when we call open, so we say please prepare for execution, we again of course store my
left and right side.
and I say okay I have to read from the left remember step meets I will need from the left
and then I must remember where so where am I currently on the left or on the right side
okay then if somebody calls next says please give me the next 1000 values
then of course I allocate an area of size 1000
and I have a right pointer here this means how many how much of this area I have already written
initially nothing of course.
Now here comes the real work and you barely can squeeze it on a single slide,
there is actually quite a lot of stuff here.
So we have an infinite loop and then I check if my current position,
so cr is my current position on the right hand side,
if my current position on the right hand side is equal to the limit of the right hand side,
this means that I hit the end of my current block from the right.
And remember that we set all these values to zero initially,
so this is in the first call this happens already,
Because I said my right hand block is processed, I mean I have no right hand block.
So then I advance my current position on the left hand side, and here, and then I add one
and then I check is my current position beyond the limit of my left hand side, this will
always be true in the first carol.
Then I fetch the next block from the left hand side, so this gives me a table from the
left.
and then i check is my left side done so if my left block empty if yes
the left box is empty if yes i set the length of r' here to my writer because i might have in
previous loop iterations already stored output tuples in my buffer therefore i cannot just say
i'm done you you must keep what you already have so you take a right position you adjust your length
of r then return up r' then you turn r' saying this is what i got
Otherwise, if there are more tables from the left,
what I do here is,
I remember my current position from the left is zero,
limit of the size of one block
that I get from the left, of course.
Okay, then I fetch the next block from the right.
I do the same check, is my right hand side done?
If yes, here we need a new function ID, namely rewind.
I must tell my right hand side, you know what?
I have to read you again because for the next block,
From the left, I again must process all tables from the right.
So if I rewrite my right hand side,
I mean this depends on how you implement this,
this roughly corresponds to just calling open.
I usually will implement it slightly differently,
but this means you tell your right hand side,
I have to read you again.
And this is roughly like open,
even though the implementation
will probably be slightly different.
So this is what rewrite does.
So remember my right current position limit and then comes, so this is if you want the exception case.
So this is the exception case, namely when you run out of work, most of the work is spent in that part here.
So I take my right position, W, and then I store at my right position the combination of C of here,
so the combination of the current tupper on the left and the current tupper on the right.
So remember we do a cross product, we combine every tuple with every other tuple, so we combine left and right.
And then I advance the pointer here to my current position on the right, because I've
combined this already, and then I also advanced my right pointer.
And if the right pointer hits my limit, so I see I've written my block as full, then I output the block.
Otherwise, the loop continues, I check.
Did I hit the end of the right hand side? If not, I do continue processing.
and so on.
So this is the processing and you see already,
this is quite involved.
So it's not so easy.
In this, even for a block,
sort of cross-strain,
there's a super simple operator,
but even here, it's not so simple
because the block-wise processing,
just like the iterator model,
has to keep a complicated state.
And so we must remember where are we?
And this where are we are basically this, this flex here.
And so these are the flex that we have to store.
we have to mean for cross products not too bad,
but for adjusting things like outer joints or so,
then it's quite complicated,
but you have to store to remember where you are in processing.
And so state can be quite involved.
Okay.
And I see now checking the time,
oh, I'm already over time.
So I will stop you for now
and we will do the examples in the push model
in the next lecture.
Okay.
Thank you.